[Música]
'actualidad económica' aquí en directo
américa a visión nocturna me acompaña en
el estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches gracias por acompañarnos y
comenzamos hablando de economía
relacionada con los precios de los
alimentos y la energía que han aumentado
debido a la guerra en ucrania santiago
varios organismos mundiales ya comienzan
a alertar de que este significativo
aumento de precios podría perdurar
incluso hasta tres años según el último
informe de previsiones de los mercados
de materias primas que hizo el banco
mundial detalla que el precio de la
energía está sufriendo su mayor
incremento desde la crisis del petróleo
de 1973 y el aumento podría superar el
50 por ciento en este 2002 según el
banco o mundial los incrementos de
precios de elementos y fertilizantes han
sido los mayores desde 2008 por su parte
la organización de las naciones unidas
para la alimentación y la agricultura
advirtió que los altos precios de los
fertilizantes otra consecuencia de la
guerra hará caer su uso en latinoamérica
y podría generar también una menor
producción agrícola y calidad
alimenticia el año que viene para
entender el impacto de la guerra desde
los productores de alimentos conversamos
con guillermo eres el ex coordinador del
sistema alimentario sostenible de la
organización recortó le preguntamos si
una escasez de alimentos es probable y
esto dijo el portó de producción a se ha
elevado de insein ty 2% pero en los
mercados el precio se ha mantenido
porque la oferta lo que hace el
consumidor es disminuir que se compraba
x cantidad ahora va a disminuir esa
equis cantidad y va a comprar menos pero
no va a estar dispuesto a pagar más
entonces el productor por lo tanto su
margen se le disminuye también y es el
gran riesgo que tenemos que si los
pequeños productores
estiman de que ya la producción ya no le
es rentable ahí donde vamos a tener la
de alimento jorge muchos se preguntarán
como una guerra en ucrania en la región
del donbass y en el sur de este país
puede afectar la alimentación en nuestra
región en américa latina' te lo explico
santiago rusia y ucrania son
exportadores netos de productos
agrícolas y ambos desempeñan un papel
clave en el suministro de los mercados
mundiales de alimentos según la fao esta
concentración de la producción global
podría aumentar la volatilidad de los
mercados de materias primas alimentos y
fertilizantes latinoamérica está
expuesta al aumento de estos precios de
los fertilizantes porque es bastante
dependiente de sus importaciones y
muchos de ellos provienen inclusive de
rusia sólo en 2021 rusia y ucrania se
situaron entre los tres principales
exportadores mundiales de trigo maíz
semillas de colza semillas de girasol y
también el aceite mientras rusia que es
el más grande productor actualmente de
fertilizantes nitro 2 y es el segundo
proveedor mundial de fertilizantes
potásicos y fosforados una solución que
se plantea a esta problemática es volver
a las prácticas ancestrales de
producción y recurrir por ejemplo a lo
biofertilizante pero esa transición
podría tardar hasta cuatro años según
los expertos le preguntamos a nuestro
invitado cómo sería esa transición en
américa latina y esto dijo
de los países que tienen más
monocultivos por decir trigo de maíz en
grandes de áreas de tierra en países
como méxico argentina brasil son países
que tienen destinan a la producción
agrícola mucha área
sustituir químicos en esas grandes áreas
por biofertilizantes un trabajo muy muy
muy grande es un gran desafío el que
tenemos no así en los países pequeños
donde la producción está mucha
producción está en manos de pequeños
productores con áreas menores nosotros
fuera acá tenemos la medida de manzana
que es como un 0.7 hectáreas
en áreas muy pequeñas es más fácil ir
incorporando los biofertilizantes
pero es
precisamente ese es el gran desafío
donde tienen que entrar en juego no sólo
ya los productores sino que tiene que
traer un juego es todo una política
acordémonos que estamos hablando de
producción de alimentos y ahí donde
tienen que tomar conciencia
el gobierno y todos los sectores porque
muchas gracias por este análisis y por
esta explicación a continuación kobe 19
la semana en américa sigan con nosotros
[Música]